إنه يكمن في حقيقة أن أحد
الشركات
ميجا يخطط للإفراج عن مدني
الطائرات التي يزداد الطلب عليها في
اقتصاد وطني
من المقرر أن تمر الطائرة
برامج التعبير العام
شرائه بالتسلسل من التاسع عشر
غدا سنكون هنا في المصابيح
تقدم لإمكاناتنا
مشترين من
[موسيقى]
محطات موقع البصريات الجديدة
انخفاض كبير في الرادار
زادت الرؤية من 6 إلى 8 بوصات
نقاط تعليق عجلة السماح
استخدام كل من الحالي والمستقبلي
قواعد وأسلحة الطائرات
بما في ذلك أسلحة الليزر
[موسيقى]
يطير الهدف مظاهرة
خصائص الاستقرار و
المناورة والقدرة على المناورة
أهداف الرحلة ونتائجها
تم تحقيق جميع الأنظمة بالكامل
تعمل القوة المحمولة جوا بشكل طبيعي
تركيب نظام تحكم متكامل
عملت الطائرة بانتظام
تصنيف الطاقم إيجابي